has a new star and a sinfully delicious
dessert concept and it's called The
Dalai Lama it just opened up here and
here to tell us more about it is
co-franchisee Charlene Davis welcome
Charlene thank you for having me I love
this concept because there's one thing
that I've been wanting to try and I'm so
glad you guys have it it's the bubble
waffle if you don't know what the bubble
waffle is I mean you have so much more
we're gonna get to that but let's talk a
little bit about this bubble waffle okay
um the bubble waffle it's originated
from Hong Kong street food it's light
it's fluffy it's Airy it's delicious
it's like the perfect waffle and the
Dalai Lama you guys are here in Las
Vegas now you're just right next to UNLV
right yes in the University garden
center across from UNLV
um it's a great location I bet I bet you
get a lot of business over there tell us
about the concept of The Dalai Lama so
the Dalai Lama is originated in 2017 by
Eric shomoff and Sam burrow and it comes
from a llama named Dolly which came from
France on a farm that's Sam visited and
you have all the sweets the bubble
waffle which we talked about you've got
just regular waffles here too um yes
it's our OG waffle it's more like a
Belgium waffle Sam actually sent two of
his chefs to France to master the waffle
so that we could have a great waffle to
Showcase I love it there's just so many
variations but that's not the only star
there the star also is some of the ice
cream flavors that you guys have tell us
a little bit about this beautiful Beast
right here this one's our Ube ice cream
Ube is like a Islander a Filipino
Hawaiian flavor but um it's delicious
you should try it I am gonna try it oh
my gosh and tell us about some of the
other fun things that you can get over
at the Dalai Lama we do have um horchata
ice cream our signature items sugar and
spice it's really good we have ultimate
Cookie Monster which is a blue ice cream
but it's vanilla with Oreos and cookie
dough oh my gosh this is so amazing this
Ube ice cream
I just wanted to eat this whole thing
right now oh my gosh tell us about all
right so we also have our signature
milkshakes um they're very popular we
have our Dalai Lama milkshake our Cinna
levers our coffee snob you can also get
fresh pints from us we pack them right
then and there for you you choose your
flavor and we pack the Pint we also have
our OG
box it's our six piece box you can
choose the waffles any sauces or
toppings and they're 75 cents each okay
again if people want to check out the
Dalai Lama where are you guys located we
are right across the street from UNLV in
the University Gardens parking I'm
literally gonna eat this entire scoop of
Ube ice cream and this is the best thing
I've ever had thank you so much thank
you for having us